SERIOUS WARNING FROM THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE ABOUT THE THREAT
FROM KIM JONG UN.
NEW INFORMATION TONIGHT THAT
DONALD TRUMP GOT A DIRE WARNING
ABOUT A MAJOR NATIONAL SECURITY
THREAT HE'LL FACE WHEN HE ENTERS
THE OVAL OFFICE.
A THREAT THAT COMES FROM A
YOUNG, IMPETUOUS DICTATOR WHO
EXECUTED HIS OWN UNCLE.
U.S. INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS TELL
CNN THE WHITE HOUSE IS CONVEYING
THAT NORTH KOREA A IS A
NEAR-TERM THREAT TO AMERICA.
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL" SAYS
THE OBAMA TEAM VIEWED NORTH
KOREA AS TRUMP'S TOP NATIONAL
SECURITY PRIORITY AND WARNED THE
TRANSITION TEAM ABOUT THE
THREAT.
>> ONCE THE PRESIDENT-ELECT GOT
THE DETAILED BRIEFINGS ON THE
STATE OF NORTH KOREAN NUCLEAR
AND MISSILE PROGRAMS, I IMAGINE
IT WAS NEW INFORMATION AND
RATHER JARRING.
>> Reporter: U.S. OFFICIALS AND
WEAPONS EXPERTS SAY KIM JONG
UN'S REGIME PROBABLY HAS THE
ABILITY ALREADY TO PUT NUCLEAR
WEAPONS ON MISSILES TO HIT JAPAN
AND SOUTH KOREA.
>> THEY'VE TESTED THE ICBM
ENGINE.
IT MAY HAVE NEW FUELS GIVING IT
GREATER RANGE AND INTENSITY.
WITH THAT NEW RANGE THE KN-14
CAN POSSIBLY REACH WASHINGTON,
D.C..
>> Reporter: THE MISSILES HAVE
NOT YET BEEN TESTED TO REENTER
THE ATMOSPHERE BUT EXPERTS SAY
THE NORTH KOREANS COULD BE ABLE
TO FIRE THE MISSILES AT THE U.S.
DURING TRUMP'S ADMINISTRATION.
THERE ARE ALSO NEW CONCERNS
TONIGHT ABOUT KIM'S VIOLENT
TENDENCIES AND HOW PRESIDENT
TRUMP WILL DEAL WITH HIM
PERSONALLY.
WHAT SHOULD HE KNOW ABOUT KIM
JONG UN AS AN ADVERSARY?
>> HE IS A DANGEROUS MAN.
HE HAS GROWN UP AROUND VIOLENCE.
HE SEEMS TO EVEN ENJOY VIOLENCE.
HE HAS BRUTALLY KILLED DOZENS OF
HIS GENERALS.
HE IS A LEADER WITHOUT
LEGITIMACY.
HE NEEDS TO PROVE TO THE KOREAN
PEOPLE'S ARMY THAT IS A TOUGH
GUY.
>> Reporter: ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL TRUMP ALTERNATED BETWEEN
SAYING IT'S POSSIBLE HE COULD
MEET WITH KIM AND SAYING HE
WANTS TO PUSH HIM OUT OF POWER.
>> HE IS LIKE A MANIAC, OKAY.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE HIM CREDIT.
HOW MANY YOUNG GUYS.
HE WAS LIKE 26 OR 25 WHEN HIS
FATHER DIED, TAKE OVER THE TOUGH
GENERALS.
>> Reporter: ANALYSTS HAVE A
SERIOUS QUESTION.
ARE THE TWO LEADERS WHO WILL ACT
RATIONALLY OR COMPULSIVELY
TOWARDS EACH OTHER.
>> KIM TAKES INSULTS SERIOUSLY.
WE'VE SEEN THREATS OF 9/11 STYLE
ATTACKS AFTER THE MOVIE "THE
INTERVIEW" WAS RELEASED.
MR. TRUMP IS ABLE TO RESPOND